ولايه تتجدد في قرن جديد التغيير الذي
انتظرته شريحه كبيره في تركيا لم يحدث
زاردوغان الاتراك لم يقتنعوا بمشروع
المعارضه التي نجحت لاول مره في الطريق في
التاريخ في الوصول لدور ثاني للفوضى التي
اعقبت الزلزال ولا مشكلات الاقتصاد اثرت
في شعبيه اردوغان في مناطق الانظار
العميقه اعلانو النصر رافقته احتفالات
عارمه لكنها لم تدم طويلا فتح فصل
التحديات القائمه والجديده ومهمه اردوغان
لن تكون سهله
لم يخسر احد اليوم 85 مليون فائز نقدر
المسؤوليه الممنوحه لنا من قبل امتنا لا
نشعر بالاهانه او الاستياء او الغضب من اي
شخص لقد حان الوقت الان لوضع كل الخلافات
والصراعات التي شهدتها فتره الانتخابات
متحده حول اهدافنا واحلامنا الوطنيه
كثيره ستشهدها تركيا والبدايه من اقوى
تحالفا للمعارضه معارضه شهدته تركيا
الحديثه الطويله السداسيه وهي التي تضم
احزابا من طيارات مختلفه لم يجمعها الا
مشروع الاطاحه باردغان لكن الخساره كانت
مزدوجه كرسي الرئاسه والانتخابات
البرلمانيه وبما ان الانتخابات المحليه لم
يعد يفصلها سوى ثمانيه اشهر ارتفعت اصواته
التغيير داخل الاحزاب المعارضه وزير
الدوله السابق محمد سيفيجان الذي شكك في
فعاليه الداعمين الخمسه
باطلاق النار عليه من الخلف وذلك بسبب عدم
خروجهم للولايات لحشد الناخبين مطالب
التغيير وصلت لحزب اكليش دار اوغلو حزب
الشعب الجمهوري طلبات عن جو اوزكان
باستقاله كلش دار اوغلو بعد ان خسر امام
اردوغان ووصفه بالطاعون الذي سياكل رقبه
كل من يدعمه في الاستمرار ميرال
زعيمه الحزب الجيد حازت المرتبه الخامسه
في البرلمان وبعد ان وعدت مؤيديها
بالانتصار وهو ما جعل رئيس لجنه الانضباط
في حزبها يدعوها الى الاستقاله الفوريه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات